JONATHAN: Happy Halloween.
Welcome to Talks at
Google in Cambridge, Mass.
It's great to see
such a big crowd.
I think we all know
why we're here,
because this office is such a
huge supporter of neuroscience.
I'm sure I'm not
the only person who
subscribes to alerts
on Google Scholar.
Tim Verstynen, faculty
at Carnegie Mellon today,
this is just a small
sample of his papers.
His co-author, Bradley Voytek
of UC San Diego, similarly.
These are giants in the field.
They're also pioneers in the
field of zombie research.
And there's not a
lot more to say.
I know their parents are
exceptionally proud of them.
I know we're eager
to hear what Tim
has to say about developments
in this emerging field
that he is helping
to blaze a path in.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming the
author of this seminal
and groundbreaking book, "Do
Zombies Dream of Undead Sheep?:
A Neuroscientific View of the
Zombie Brain, Tim Verstynen.
TIM VERSTYNEN:
Thank you, Jonathan.
And Happy Halloween everybody.
Thanks for coming.
Before I get into
it, I just would
like point out that my
collaborator, Bradley Voytek,
and I have kind of
teamed up on this.
And what you're going
to see is a hobby
that's gone out of hand.
We are both zombie geeks.
And how this started was
that in graduate school,
we were both in
the same program.
And on our off hours,
we liked to just geek
out and watch zombie movies.
And being nerds,
we decided, well,
what would happen
with the zombie brain?
And it all went
downhill from there.
So you're about to see
the aftermath of that.
But before I really get into
the nitty gritty details, just
a disclaimer, I'm going to be
showing clips from some zombie
movies, primarily "Night
of the Living Dead,"
because it's the best
zombie movie ever.
So there's going
to be a little bit
of 1960-style gore
and some spoilers.
So just be warned.
All right.
So I get asked
this question a lot
by my colleagues
in neuroscience,
why zombie neuroscience?
Why are we doing this silly
endeavour on our off hours
instead of writing
another grant?
Well, Brad and I are both big
science outreach advocates.
And one of the things
we're interested in
is trying to get general
audiences more engaged
with basic science information.
By and large, the way
the broader public
gets science is filtered through
types of media sources that
try to spin and make big
mountains out of small mole
hills.
And often, it gets distorted.
So we need to get the
general public more engaged
in the real core
scientific literature.
So we've thought about
possibilities of doing this.
One, we thought about using
internet memes as our figures
to illustrate our findings.
So use your LOL Cat to
display Hebbian networks.
That didn't go over so well.
We pondered, accidentally,
releasing sex tapes
during our lectures to get a
broader audience coming in.
Our lawyers suggested
that we don't do that.
And we thought, well, maybe
we could attract more readers
to our journal
articles if we just
added a Kardashian
to the author list.
Again, apparently, you
need their permission
in order to put them
on the author list.
So this didn't work.
And each one of these approaches
has the following structure.
What we're doing is we're
trying to take aspects
of popular culture and inject
it into science to pull people
into the basic science.
And it's kind of hard to do.
So what we need to do
is instead flip this
and say, bring science
into popular culture.
How can we start bringing your
real scientific principles
into popular culture in
order to educate the broader
public on scientific issues?
And so this was
our first attempt
at this kind of leveraging
science information
into popular culture.
And so, of course, us
beings zombie nerds,
well, we're going to take
a look at zombies first.
They're actually
a perfect example
for exploring neuroscientific
ideas in this broader context.
So that's why
zombie neuroscience.
So for the next about half
an hour or so, bear with me.
We're going to be
suspending our disbelief
and pretending that outside
around Kendall Square,
the undead are walking around.
In fact, on a Halloween
like today, there probably
are undead walking
around Kendall Square.
So welcome to "The Science
of Surviving the Zombie
Apocalypse," more importantly,
the neuroscience of it.
So as a scientist and as a
neuroscientist, in particular,
when I see a zombie
like this woman here,
I see an undead creature, yes.
But I also see a spectrum
of very particular types
of behaviors that
you see repeated
again and again and again
in "The Walking Dead."
You see things like
hyper-aggression,
memory deficits,
attention problems.
You'll see language disruption,
reduced impulse control,
movement disorders, and even
visual recognition impairments.
And these are seen across
almost every genre of the zombie
movie.
So as a neuroscientist,
this tells us
something very interesting.
This gives us some
pretty key insights
into what's happened to
this individual's brain
as she's gone from being
a high school cheerleader
into being a ravenous zombie.
So using this collective
set of behaviors
that have changed
into zombie, we
were able to
actually reconstruct
a model of what the
zombie brain looks like.
So let me show you
our model here.
So on the left right here is a
normal, neurologically healthy
human individual.
There's lots of tissue packed
into a really small space,
so it's very wrinkly.
And it's a very robust,
healthy looking structure.
On the right is
the zombie brain.
And what you see is
lots of big gaps,
lots of space that's unused.
In fact, this
little guy back here
is completely gone
in the zombie brain.
We're going to get to
that a little bit later.
So this shows atrophy
in the zombie brain.
And this atrophy that
you're seeing isn't random.
Each one of the areas that's
decayed away in the zombie
brain reflects a very
particular symptom
that we see in zombieism
So the goal of "Do Zombies
Dream of Undead Sheep?"
is to take apart
the behavior of zombies
and link it back up
to each one of these brain
regions that's been atrophied
and destroyed in zombie brain.
So that's what we're
going to do today
and just looking at a
few of these symptoms.
Now, before we do,
we're scientists.
We like to take what seems
like supernatural phenomenon
and make it dry and boring
and clinically defined.
So we're going to
define zombieism
not as zombies, but as
a clinical disorder.
And so we're going to call
it Consciousness Deficit
Hypoactivity
Disorder, CDHD, which
is defined as the loss of
rational, voluntary, and
conscious behavior
that's been replaced
by delusional/impulsive
aggression,
stimulus-driven attention,
and the inability
to coordinate motor or
linguistic behaviors.
There, we've stripped
away all the really weird
supernatural stuff and made
it a nice, clean studyable
phenomenon.
Also, with a cool
name like CDHD,
maybe we can get a
pharmaceutical company
to fund our research.
All right, so from
now on, we're going
to be calling zombieism CDHD.
And we're going
to try to explore
the neural underpinnings
of CDHD by going
through a set of symptoms
that we see with the disorder.
So the first symptom or the
first behavioral characteristic
that people notice when
they encounter the undead
is their hyper-aggression.
Let's see an example
of this behavior.
This is Karen.
Karen's just recently
turned to the undead.
And here she's, I believe,
eating the arm of her father.
And let's see what happens when
Karen runs into her mother.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Karen.
Karen?
Karen.
Oh baby.
Baby.
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN:
Because you always
got to get the garden shears.
-Ah.
Aaaah.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: OK,
we'll save you the blood
and gore there.
But I think it's pretty
safe to say that Karen's
pretty angry with
her mother, right?
Most normal kids who are
not angry with their parents
don't grab a garden shear
and start stabbing them.
So this type of
aggression is interesting
because it's very reflective of
a well-described type of anger
known as reactive-impulsive
aggression.
This is, and this
is a quote from
an actual scientific paper,
"a subtype of aggression that
can result in sudden,
heightened, enduring, or
inappropriate
aggressive responses."
So this is the stimulus-driven
type of aggression
that you'll see when you engage
the body's fight or flight
responses.
And it's very different than the
type of aggression you see in
say something like a
school shooting, which
is a very calculated, decisive,
cool type of aggression.
And we know a lot about
the neural underpinnings
of this reactive-impulsive
aggression, what we sometimes
call as road rage aggression.
So this type of
aggressive behavior
is well-characterized
in many animal models.
So we've laid out a lot of
the neural circuits that
drive this type of response.
So let's take a look at
those neural circuits.
The control of aggression,
normally in hopefully everyone
in this room, is
regulated by areas
in the front of the brain
in the prefrontal cortex,
usually around what's known
as the orbital frontal cortex
or complex.
And this is a set of
higher level brain areas
that regulate a lot
of different things.
But one of the things they
do is they regulate control
in subcortical
networks, networks
that are buried
deep in the brain.
And in particular, one
area known as the amygdala
receives extensive input from
this orbital frontal complex.
And what this does is it
acts as like a cooling
mechanism for amygdala function.
So the orbitofrontal cortex
is doing the, shh, it's OK.
It's OK.
And the amygdala
is hypersensitive
to potential threats
in the environment.
It's always looking
for a threat.
So if we wanted to couch this
in Freudian terms,-- and please,
I hope my department chair
doesn't hear me talking about
Freud in this talk-- you can
think of the amygdala as being
the id and the orbitofrontal
cortex is being superego.
It's trying to keep this
reactive, primal, instinctive
fight or flight response intact.
So the amygdala
controls aggression
through a very particular set
of interactions between areas
known as the hypothalamus and
thalamus, which in turn send
excitatory projections to
an area of the brain known
as the periaqueductal gray.
This is buried deep,
deep in the brain.
And the periaqueductal
gray stimulates
your arousal mechanisms.
So it's what gets you ramped up,
and in this case, aggressive.
So normally, the prefrontal
cortex is saying calm down.
Don't react.
That guy cut you off in traffic.
Don't throw a brick
through his window.
But if you remove the
orbitofrontal cortex
from the equation, what
happens is the subcortical
fight or flight
responses are unchecked.
So you get an unconstrained
amygdala response,
which through this
network of other areas,
increases sensitivity
to reactive behaviors.
And what you get if you wipe
out those prefrontal control
mechanisms is you get a
unconstrained, impulsive rage.
You get more appetite
diregulation, chronic stress
responses.
You'll even get
appetite disregulation.
So these are all behaviors that
you see in animals with damage
to the orbitofrontal areas.
And you also see it in zombies.
So I think it's a
pretty good guess
that that's what we're
seeing, at least in this case,
with zombies.
So if we look at the human
brain and the zombie brain side
by side, the
orbitofrontal areas that
tend to control those
type of reactive response
rest right up here.
This is the front side of
the brain, looking at front.
And this is the underview
of the brain here.
If we look at the
zombie brain, we
see an atrophy of these
prefrontal networks.
So that control
region has gone away.
But that's not all.
We don't just see extensive
damage to the zombie brain.
We actually see some
plasticity as well.
So if we look at those
subcortical areas,
like the amygdala
and the thalamus--
so this is a slice through
the brain right about here
on the left showing
the amygdala in red.
And this guy in the right, this
is a slice through the brain
this way showing the thalamus.
If we look at the volume of
these two subcortical areas,
the humans are displayed
in gray and zombies
are displayed in orange.
And we see-- actually, these
areas should be bigger.
These areas are more
enlarged in the zombie,
or the CDHD subtypes, than
what you see in humans.
So they're unconstrained.
They're using more resources and
they're building more neurons.
So they're becoming
more sensitive.
So this explains
a little bit how
you have this reactive
aggression in the zombie brain.
So let's look at another
symptom of the zombie epidemic,
or the CDHD epidemic.
Let's look at
visual recognition.
I'm going to show you two scenes
of the same two individuals.
The first is a scene before
this gentleman here, Johnny,
has turned.
And this is his sister Barbara.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-To really be scared here.
-Johnny.
-You're still afraid.
-Stop it now.
I mean it.
-They're coming to
get you, Barbara.
-Stop it.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN:
OK, so it's very
obvious he knows who
this person is, right?
Now, let's look at Johnny
after he's become a zombie.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-No.
No, get out.
No.
No Johnny, no.
No, no,
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN:
So, notice he doesn't
have that glint of
recognition in his eye.
He doesn't see his sister.
He just sees a human that
he can devour, right?
He doesn't recognize her at all.
This seems to be a
common phenomenon
throughout the zombie genre.
You see it many times, two
high school sweethearts.
One gets bitten and
turns into a zombie.
As soon as they turn
into the zombie,
they start to eat the
cheek of their loved one
because they no
longer recognize them.
They just react as if this
is just some random person
that they can devour.
And this type of visual
recognition problem
resembles a well-described
psychiatric disorder
known as Capgras Delusion.
Capgras Delusion
is the false belief
that the people you know well
have been replaced by impostors
and are typically
seen of as a threat.
This is the invasion of the body
snatchers psychiatric disorder,
It's a very real disorder.
So you wake up one
morning and suddenly,
that's not your wife
laying next to you.
That's some alien that's
inhabited your wife's body.
She might look, sound,
talk like my wife,
but she's not really my wife.
This isn't always bad.
There was a case
report of a woman
who was in a miserable
marriage for years.
She had a stroke,
developed Capgras Delusion
and was convinced that
her husband was replaced
by Casanova and
that she was having
illicit affair
with this Casanova
that was in her husband's body.
And their love life
actually improved.
So it's not always bad.
But Capgras Delusion is
a psychiatric problem,
which means it's characterized
at this behavioral level,
but we don't really know the
neural underpinnings of it.
But the phenomenon
is very similar
to a well-described
neurological phenomenon
known as prosopagnosia.
Prosopagnosia is the inability
to delink a person's identity
to the visual image
of their face.
So in the classic scenario,
somebody with prosopagnosia,
you stand them in front
of a mirror and say, who's
looking back at you?
And they won't be able
to tell you who they are.
They'll just say, I see a face.
I see that person.
They've got a beard.
But I don't know who they are.
Or another famous example
is an experimenter
will be showing a set
of faces on the screen.
The experimenter's face
will come on the screen.
The experimenter's
right here and the guy
asks, who are you
seeing on the screen?
And the patient will
reply, I don't know.
Somebody.
So this type of
disorder has been
described in the neurological
literature for about 100 years
or so now.
And it's linked to
disorders or damage
to a particular network of areas
in the brain known as the face
network.
OK So the face
network, particularly
an area known as the
fusiform face area
are a well-described
set of brain areas
that are sensitive
to seeing faces
more than any other object.
In fact, the face area
was first described at MIT
by Nancy Kanwisher
about 20 years ago.
So the way the face
network is characterized
is let's say I put you in an
MRI and look at the functional
activation of your brain
when I show you pictures.
So I show you a picture
of this dude here.
And then I show you
pictures of houses or cars.
And I say, which areas are
more active to this face
than to these cars?
Well, what you
would see is a set
of regions in the
back of the head
on the underside
of the neocortex.
So each one of these blobs
here shows a separate region
that's more responsive to
this face than anything else.
This is sometimes known
as the core face network.
And what these are is a set of
well-connected brain regions
that basically deconstruct
the visual image of the face,
reassemble it, and link it
categorically to an individual.
So it's a stream of information,
starting in the back
where the primary
visual cortex is
that just sees spatial features,
and keeps moving forward
to higher level
areas of the brain
until it's linked up to a face.
So damage to any
part of this network
can lead to prosopagnosia.
And I'm going to show you
an interesting example
of temporarily
induced prosopagnosia.
What we're going
to see is a patient
is about ready to
undergo neurosurgery.
He's got a tumor
in the underside
of his brain near that
core face network.
And surgeons want
to resect the tumor,
but they don't want to
make him prosopagnosiac.
So what they did is they
implanted stimulators
on the underside of his brain.
And what they're
going to do is they're
going to stimulate
different parts
and see where does his face
perception get disrupted.
And that way, they can map out
where the face selective areas
are and the neurosurgeon
can work around them.
So you're going to
see two trials here.
In one trial, the
experimenter isn't
going to deliver any
stimulation at all.
In the second trial,
they're actually
going to deliver stimulation.
So this took place in Stanford.
And this patient has no
neuroscience or psychology
background whatsoever.
So he doesn't know
what's going on.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Just look at my
face and tell me
what happens when I
do this, all right?
-OK.
-One, two, three.
-Nothing.
OK.
I'm going to do
it one more time.
Look at my face.
One, two, three.
-You just turned
into somebody else.
-Tell me about it.
-Your face metamorphised.
Your nose got saggy.
It went to the left.
You almost looked like
somebody I had seen before,
somebody different.
That was a trip.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: I
love that last line.
So just a brief stimulation
of these face areas--
in this particular case, it was
the fusiform form face area--
caused this disruption of
the perception of the face.
And so as the clip goes on,--
I don't have time to show you
the entire clip-- the
experimenter keeps turning down
the voltage and keeps
turning down the current.
And eventually he says,
your face didn't change.
I just didn't know you were you.
So the disconnect between
seeing the face and the identity
of the experimenter-- he was
looking at the experimenter.
He knew who this person
was-- just got disconnected.
So this is a great example
of a transiently induced
prosopagnosia.
The whole image of the
face just got torn apart.
So the face network is part
of a larger visual network
in the brain known as the
ventral visual stream.
And so this is the ventral
visual stream in one
of our zombie
experimental subjects.
So this is the primary visual
cortex here and information
that flows on the
underside of the brain,
mostly along the temporal lobe.
And this is the
undercurrent here.
It's part of the
ventral visual stream.
So this is the fusiform face
area I talked about earlier.
This is known classically
as the "What" pathway.
It's the pathway
in your brain that
tries to assemble
object knowledge
and recognize
objects in the world.
So if we look at this
"What" pathway in a human,
if we did a slice right
through the brain--
this would be a saggital
slice right through here.
This is the main core
of the "What" pathway
on the left and right side.
In the zombie brain,
the "what" pathway
would be extensively damaged.
So they would have impaired face
knowledge, object knowledge.
And this is actually
where the fusiform face
area sits in the
right hemisphere.
So we're going to say
that not only are zombies
losing the prefrontal
control of their aggression.
They've also lost the
ability to recognize
faces in other objects
with few exceptions.
Another classic
deficit we see in CDHD
all the time is language.
Zombies don't talk.
In fact, I'm going to show
you an example of the most
fluent zombie we know of,
if you ignore that movie
"Warm Bodies."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Brains.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN:
OK, that's Tar Man.
Tar Man is the individual who
single handedly linked brains
to zombies.
Up until Tar Man, brains
and zombies weren't linked.
Zombies would eat
any part of the body.
They would go for the liver
before they'd go for the brain.
But Tar Man had a
particular taste for brains.
And so he was the one who was
always going after brains.
But I want you to
notice something.
Here, he was asking
this teenager
if he could eat her brains.
But he didn't say,
can you come over
here so that I can
eat your brains
or please come by because your
gray matter looks delicious.
No, he just said, brains.
You got the idea, but it
was a single-word sentence.
That type of
phenomenon, if we see it
in clinical
neurological patients,
is known as telegraphia.
So the idea being that patients
who are having difficulty
getting words out will resort
to just the most critical parts
of the sentence, the most
critical semantic parts
of the sentence, and take
away all the other fluency.
And the name comes
from the old telegraph
for long-distance communication
a hundred and some years ago.
In that case, you
paid by the character.
So you had to make your notes
short, sweet, and to the point.
The same is true
with these patients.
They have trouble
getting out words.
So the whole idea
just to get out
the key, most important
parts of the sentence.
Now telegraphia is
a symptom that you
see in a larger class of
disorders known as aphasias.
And aphashias are broad
term that reflect, really,
any language deficit, but
there's many sub-types.
So for example,
there's the inability
to produce language,
which is classically
known as Broca's aphasia,
or difficulty comprehending
language, which is classically
known as Wernicke's aphashia.
And each one of these two areas
has different cortical sources
that play a larger part in the
language networks of the brain.
So this is Tar Man in here
holding his favorite dish.
So this is the human
brain right here.
We're looking in the left side.
So Broca's area is
right up here in front.
And this is the area
that if you damage
it gets you Broca's aphasia.
It's tightly linked up
to the motor cortex.
And it's single handedly linked
to the language production
end of things.
So it's what forms
your mouth movements
and your gestural patterns
to producing language.
In the back, right
by the temporal lobe
and the parietal
lobe, where they meet,
you see Wernicke's area,
which is a region that's
linked to language
comprehension.
So if you damage Wernicke's
area, you can get words out.
They're just discombobulated.
They're not well-structured.
You also have difficulty
understanding people.
And these two areas
are connected together
by a very large bundle of
white matter pathways known
as the arcuate fasciculus.
These are big superhighways
of the brain that
connect Wernicke
and Broca's area.
When you think about as
language, what you're doing
is you're constructing the
idea and semantics of what
you're saying.
You're shipping all
that information out
to the output area of the
language circuit and saying,
ship out this information
to the rest of the world.
So information typically
flows from Wernicke's over
to Broca's.
And damage to any
one of these areas
will impair language function.
So if we look at this circuit
in the human and zombie brain,
this is the human on the left.
Broca's would be
right about up here
and Wernicke is right
about back here.
If you look in the zombie
brain, we see extensive atrophy
in both ends of the circuit.
So basically, this tells us,
don't try talking to a zombie.
They're not going
to understand you.
And they're not really
going to talk back,
except for maybe
asking for your brains.
So this could
explain how you get
these sorts of language fluency
problems in the CDHD disorder.
The final symptom I'm going to
go over for CDHD is movement.
And this is what really
when you ask somebody
to pretend to be a zombie,
the first thing they do
is move and walk like a zombie.
So let's see a classic
zombie movement here.
I want you to pay
attention to how
these creatures are walking.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: All right.
So we have arms out, wide,
lumbering, stiff stance.
They tend to do this.
So there's obviously
something wrong with the way
their brains are
coordinating their actions.
So let's take a quick look
at the general circuits
in the brain that
regulate our movements.
There are three, big
collective circuits
in the brain that
drive our actions.
There's actually
many more than this.
These are just the
big sets of them.
In the neocortex, you have
the cortical motor areas.
So this is our
zombie subject here.
This is their brain.
Everything shown here in gray
are cortical motor areas.
And this is actually
a collection
of a few dozen different
areas that collectively
coordinate your actions.
And they're
responsible for things
like sensory integration,
movement planning, and movement
execution.
So they kind of plan what to
do with the marionette strings
of your muscles and joints
and coordinate those movements
together.
Underneath the motor cortex
and deep in the brain
is an area known as
the basal ganglia.
This is the second
major motor pathway.
So this little alien
looking creature in here,
that's a subcortical
nuclei and part
of the basal ganglia circuit.
And what they do is they're
responsible for gating
or inhibiting actions.
So really, they're the
gatekeepers of the movements
that you execute.
So they decide whether
or not you're actually
going to throw a brick
through a window or not.
So they kind of make that
final output decision.
And then on the back
of the head here,
this is shown
right back here, is
a little cauliflower-shaped
area of the brain
known as the cerebellum.
Cerebellum is responsible
for motor timing
and actual temporal perception
to coordination and error
correction.
So it's the quality
assessment guy
that makes sure that your
actions are being conducted
smoothly and without
major errors.
So each one of these three areas
contributes in different ways
to different types
of motor control.
Now, when most people look
at the way that zombies move,
the first thing
they'll say is, oh,
they look like they
have Parkinson's.
In fact, "Slate" just had a
write up of one of our chapters
from the book yesterday.
And their first title, before
we got them to change it, was,
"Do Zombies Have Parkinson's?"
And Parkinson's is a disorder
of the basal ganglia.
So patients with Parkinson's
lose a major pathway
in this system.
And it results in a
very particular type
of movement disorders.
But let me show you what
Parkinson's patients look
like when they have
full-blown movement disorders.
So typically, they'll
have slouched posture.
They're losing postural control.
Their hands are
closer to their sides.
And the way they walk are
short, shuffling steps.
This is a very characteristic
Parkinson's walk.
That's not what we see in
the CDHD disorder at all.
We see wide legs,
stiff, arms out.
There's a balance problems and
these kind a lumbering walks.
That kind of movement actually
resembles a different motor
disorder known as
spinocerebellar ataxia.
So individuals with SCA,
or spinocerebellar ataxia,
suffer from an
inability to produce
smooth, coordinated actions.
And it results in these kind
of lumbering movements, balance
problems, tremors, slurred
speech, visual eye movement
problems, so a host of
different movement problems.
And they all resolve
around the fact
that patients with this
disorder are suffering
from a degeneration of
the cerebellum itself.
So the cerebellum
atrophies away and it
causes these movement disorders.
In fact, if you want to
know just very little bit
what it's like to suffer
from this disorder,
think about the last
time you were drunk.
You had balance problems,
your slurred speech,
your stumbled walk.
Those are all
cerebellar symptoms,
because the alcohol's explicitly
influencing and affecting
the cerebellum.
So that's what these individuals
suffer on a daily basis,
without the euphoria of alcohol.
So those kind of movements
are very, very characteristic
of cerebellar damage.
Now, the cerebellum is probably
my favorite area of the brain.
It's kind of under
appreciated in
the neuroscientific community.
It contains half of the
neurons in the brain.
So even though the
neocortex is bigger,
the cerebellum contains
half of the neurons.
And it had a sordid history.
There were a ton of really
off the wall theories
about what the cerebellum did.
Early on, it was
thought to just regulate
the fluids of the body.
There was once a theory that it
was the battery of the brain.
So it was just doing
voltaic battery generation
in order to produce
electrical impulses.
But, perhaps, my favorite
early theory of the cerebellum
came from the phrenologists.
The phrenologists were
the early neuroscientists
who tried to map out
lumps on the head
with certain personality
characteristics.
And the phrenologists
thought that the cerebellum
was the root of the libido.
They thought that
all your sexual drive
came from the cerebellum.
And they were scientists.
I like to knock
the phrenologists,
but they practiced
the scientific method.
And they figured
this out because they
would go to French
prisons and then feel
bumps on the heads of
different criminals.
And they just noticed
that criminals
with chronic, habitual
masturbation problems
had larger bumps over
the back of their head
by where the cerebellum was.
So they thought, ah, they've
got large cerebellum.
So that's what's driving
these sexual impulses.
And to their credit,
they'd actually
tried an experimental
manipulation
to see if they could
prove this theory.
So in one individual,
this poor female inmate,
they strapped an ice cube
to the back of her head,
strapped it in, tied it
in, a giant block of ice,
and noticed that this inmate
stop touching yourself
when the ice cube was strapped
to the back of her head.
So voila, they proved
that the cerebellum
is responsible for the libido.
So if you're like me,
you could probably
see many different
reasons why people
would stop touching themselves
with a giant block of ice
to the back of their head.
And another
individual who shared
this theory was this gentleman
here, Pierre Fluorens.
Pierre Fluorens was a
classic neuroanatomist
and neurophysiologist.
He was really a pioneer
of early neurology.
And he thought this
was ridiculous.
So I'm going to read you
a quote from an article
about his discovery of how
the cerebellum is actually
linked to motor control.
"Fluorens dismissed as
unfounded the claims
for the sexual function
in the cerebellum.
He removed the cerebellum
of a mature rooster.
The animal was still deeply
interested in the hens,
but motor dysfunction
made it difficult
for him to express his
feelings towards them."
I love that little
delicate ending there.
So basically, the
rooster was still randy,
but he couldn't really
coordinate his actions
to make his affections known.
So this was actually
the first explicit case
showing that the cerebellum
was linked to motor control.
It didn't happen
until the mid 1800s.
So since then, we've
done a lot of work
characterizing how
the cerebellum is
linked to motor control.
Now, cerebellum sits right
back here in the humans.
And over here in
the zombie brain,
you see that the
cerebellum is pretty much
completely atrophied.
So these kinds of
movement disorders
that you see in zombies reflects
severe cerebellar dysfunction.
Any zombie movie
fan in the audience
is going to be a
little bit frustrated
at this point
because so far, I've
only been talking about one very
particular subtype of the CDHD
disorder, known as the
slow zombie subtype.
These are the
classic early forms
of the disease as we saw it.
But more recently,
another subtype
has emerged, particularly
starting around 2002, 2004.
And that's the fast
zombie be subtype.
These guys don't lumber.
They don't have
discoordinated actions.
They can climb.
If you've watched the movie
"World War Z," they can swarm.
And these are vicious,
vicious predators out there.
So we wanted to
say, OK, well, what
is the difference between
this guy and this guy?
So Brad and I flew
out to England,
grabbed ourselves a
set of fast zombies,
brought them back to the lab
and looked at their brains.
And if you compare the
brains of the slow zombie
to the fast zombie, you see
some very interesting things.
First off, you see
that the fast zombie
has an attached cerebellum.
So they still have this motor
coordination ability intact.
They also have no atrophy in
the superior parietal portions
of the brain.
These are the brain
portions up here,
which means they have actually
better spatial attention
as well.
So there's not as
extensive brain damage
in the fast zombies as what
you see in the slow zombie
variant of the CDHD disorder.
So what drives this difference?
Why do we suddenly see
this different subtype
in the disease?
Well, again, we did
extensive research.
We watched a ton
of movies and then
had to rewatch them
when we were sober.
The one thing we
noticed time and time
again was that in the
new, fast zombie subtype,
the time between infection
and resurrection of zombie
became quite short.
So we developed what
we call now the time
to resurrection hypothesis.
So according to this
hypothesis, the time
between sudden death due to
infection and resurrection,
if it's short, as you see in the
fast zombie, the amount of time
that the brain is starved
of oxygen and glucose
is relatively short.
So what happens when
the brain is starved
of oxygen and glucose is
it starts to die away.
It induces itself into this
hypoxic state and tissue
loss occurs.
So if that's
relatively short, you
don't get as extensive
of tissue loss.
But if as in the
older variant, like we
saw in "Night of
the Living Dead,"
it would take hours,
days, weeks or months
in order to resurrect.
And that's going to lead to
much more extensive damage,
because the brain is
starved of those resources
for much longer.
The cerebellum and
early visual areas
are particularly
sensitive to hypoxia.
So this would predict
that we should
see a negative correlation
between the walking
speed of an undead individual
and the time at which it
took them to resurrect.
So this could explain why we
get the two different subtypes
of the CDHD disorder.
All right.
So what might cause CDHD?
Well, there's lots of
potential pathogens
that could cause this disorder.
Viruses are known
to attack the brain.
What you're seeing
here is an individual
who had a neural infection
with the herpes simplex virus.
So everything you
see here in white
is calcified neural tissue.
This is the same
virus that gives you
cold sores in your mouth,
except every once in awhile,
instead of traveling
out a cranial nerve,
it travels up to the brain.
And it can cause
extensive damage up
in particularly the
prefrontal cortex.
But most viral damages
we know to the brain
are very nonspecific
and just very global.
They wouldn't lead to
a very specific pattern
of a global behavioral deficit.
So we don't think viruses
are what's causing the zombie
brain, much to the frustration
of the producers of "28 Days
Later."
Bacteria is another potential
source of the infection.
This is an image of
an individual who
had meningitis, which is
a bacterial infection.
And you see that meningitis
ate away, basically, the lower
quarter of this
individual's brain.
It's a massive
infectious disease.
And the damage that it does
is, again, very nonspecific.
So while viruses
and bacteria are
known to influence
the brain, they
don't lead to these coordinated,
specific regional changes
in brain tissue.
Another potential
candidate is prions.
So prions are little
forms of protein
that can unfold the cellular
structure of basically all cell
types, but particularly neurons.
And so this is a brain
image of an individual
with Creutzfeldt-Jakob's
disease.
Everything in white, again,
is areas of calcified tissue
that have been damaged.
And again, prions
are nonspecific.
Now, I apologize if you
don't sleep tonight.
But another potential
candidate is brain worms.
Yes, brain worms are real.
This is a syndrome known
as neurocysticercosis.
These arrows are pointing
to these little sacks here.
Can you guess what's
in the little sacks?
Yes, a little tape worm that
buries itself in the brain
and siphons off nutrients
from your blood supply.
And this happens from eating
fecally contaminated foods.
And we actually
think it's probably
epidemic in third
world countries.
But normally, these brain
worms don't do any harm.
They just take up a
little bit of space.
They siphon off a
little bit of resources.
But they don't cause
big behavioral problems
until you have, as
I tell you now--
one patient had three
dozen worms in his head.
He started showing
behavioral symptoms,
but that was because
his head basically
turned into Swiss cheese.
So we can imagine the case where
maybe a subtype of these worms
is forming a chemical
interaction with the brain
and leading to these slow,
specific behavioral changes.
Another hypothesis that was
put out in the literature
is if anybody seen the
movie "The Signal,"
is that TV and radio
transmissions can
emit a particular EM frequency
that causes the neuron activity
patterns to change
fundamentally.
And we know that you
can actually kill cells
by letting them just fire a lot.
So you could see coordinated
brain damage, which
we sometimes call
excitotoxicity,
induced by particular
stimulus inputs.
Again, this is the premise
for the movie "The Signal."
And at first I thought this
was silly until I saw this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC RICK ASTLEY,"NEVER GONNA
GIVE YOU UP"]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: So
I don't know about you,
but that makes me
want to kill somebody.
So I'm going to go
with the Rick Astley
theory of the CDHD disorder.
All right, so far
I've shown you how
you can look at this silly
pop culture supernatural
entity, this little zombie
here, characterize it
in a very rigorous way
in a scientific manner
where we can link up specific
behavioral traits to the brain,
and use real science
to kind of explain
a relatively silly, supernatural
organism like the zombie.
So this really
shows the potential
of trying to push
this scientific idea
into popular culture
in order to educate
real scientific principles
in the general public.
So in a way, what
we're trying to do
is keep building this bridge
between popular culture
and science and get these
to interplay more in order
to facilitate greater
scientific education.
So if you want to know more,
you can obviously read our book,
"Do Zombies Dream
of Undead Sheep?"
We also have a set of
animated videos released
through the TED-Ed foundation.
They are great supporters
of science outreach.
I love the TED-Ed foundation.
So we have two
videos up about how
to diagnose the zombie
brain and some fallacies
in using neuroimaging to explain
brain-behavior relationships.
We also have a set of colleagues
collective in the zombie
Research Society.
And this is a bunch
of academics who
use zombies to teach
their particular field.
Actually, two members of
the Zombie Research Society
are here in Boston
and Cambridge.
Dan Drezner teaches the
politics and political science
of zombies.
And he's over at Tufts.
And Steve Schlozman is at MGH.
And he's a psychiatrist.
And he does these
psychiatry of zombies.
And he actually published a
novel on the zombie disorder
as a psychiatric condition,
which is really fun.
And so if you're
not just interested
in neuroscience
but other fields,
check out the people who are
associated with the Zombie
Research Society because
they do great work like this.
So thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: So questions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I had a question about
popular zombie movies and TV
shows, where you see them as
truly scientifically inaccurate
either in general or in
specific important scenes.
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Ah.
Actually, I would say 99% of
the zombies I've seen in TVs
and movies are so unrealistic
as to make them impossible.
There are a few exceptions.
There's a video game,
"The Last of Us,"
in which a evolution of
the cordyceps fungus, which
actually induces
zombieism in ants.
Really, it does.
It somehow mutates and
causes the same thing
to happen in humans.
So you see these
zombies running around
with giant fungi
attached to their heads.
And that is one that
I thought was actually
a fairly realistic one, because
they're also not undead.
You can easily kill them.
And then the most
realistic representation
of zombies that I would say
had the biological plausibility
were the zombies in the "28
Days Later" and "28 Weeks Later"
movies.
And for those you
who haven't see them,
the premise of the movie is
that scientists in Oxford
are trying to understand rage.
And they develop a virus
known as the rage virus, which
plays with the aggression
circuits in the brain.
And it gets loose in
the general public.
And what happens is
people just being
become really just
ravenously aggressive.
They're not undead.
In fact, the premise
is that 28 days later
means that they're not
thinking about eating.
So they're going to starve
to death in 28 days.
And so you can ideally wait
out the zombie apocalypse
just by letting them
starve to death.
So I thought that
probably "28 Days Later"
was the most biologically
possible one.
But even then, the behavioral
patterns and the transmission
rates were nowhere
near plausible.
The scene that frustrated
me the most was
at the end of "The Walking
Dead's" first season when
they were in the CDC and
there was this biologically
plausible explanation of
the neuroscience of zombies
was so bad that it made me cry.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So speaking
of realistic zombies,
there's this notion
of the voodoo zombies
and being controlled by drugs
on plantations and stuff.
I'm just curious how
that plays into--
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN:
Yeah, so that's
actually another little
side tangent to mine.
Because the zombieism
that you see in Haitian
voodoo culture is quite
interesting in that it
has a proposed
neuropharmacological
explanation.
So there's a classic
book by Wade Davis, who
was an ethnobotanist,
who went down to Haiti
and made two particular
pharmacological links
to Haitian zombies.
And one was
tetrodotoxin, which was
the poison used
to simulate death.
And tetrodotoxin works by
blocking the sodium channels
that allow neurons to fire in
the peripheral nervous system.
So your muscles
become paralyzed.
And it actually won't kill
you unless your diaphragm
stops working.
So basically, it kills you
because the diaphragm muscle
stops working.
But if you get a low
enough dose, what'll happen
is that your diaphragm will
keep moving so slowly that you
can't really detect it.
But in all intents and
purposes, you look dead.
So that's the simulated death.
And then the control
aspects, he proposed
that the bokors, who are the
bad or evil voodoo priests,
would dose the individual after
the tetrodotoxin had worn off
when they dug them
out of their grave
that they were buried
alive in, would douse them
with datura, which has
three major psychoactive
ingredients, [? hyoscapines ?],
scopolamine, and atropine,
I think.
Each one of those will
induce a psychotic state.
And so the idea is that you
can make this person who
is now convinced this he's dead,
because he saw himself dead.
He was well aware of everything
that's happening to him,
felt buried.
And then he gets raised.
And then there's a
psychoactive chemical
that keeps him compliant.
That was the Wade Davis theory.
It's controversial.
It hasn't been replicated yet.
And people are saying that
there's probably other aspects
to it that link more to
psychological belief.
But yeah, the Haitian voodoo
zombie links to neurobiology
are quite interesting that way.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I had two questions.
So one was, what
causes zombieism?
And so in some forms
of movies, it's
kind of like a venomous
thing, that if you're bitten,
you're infected--
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Right.
AUDIENCE: You get it.
In other more recent ones,
it's everyone's infected.
When you die, you're a zombie.
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Right.
AUDIENCE: They're really
different outcomes.
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Right.
AUDIENCE: So I don't
know if you had
any thoughts about
that difference.
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Yeah.
The we're all infected
and we're just going
to reanimate when whenever we--
AUDIENCE: Romero--
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN:
--transition from one state.
Romero was-- so we actually
got to interview George Romero.
And we were asking him about it.
He said, the way he
made up, particularly
in his first three movies,
he didn't care about it.
He was trying to use the
zombies as a metaphor.
So in the first one,
he kept it vague.
There was the satellite from
outer space that had come back.
And it was somehow
linked to that.
But it could have
been space radiation.
And he was saying
he explicitly didn't
care about what caused it.
He just wanted them to be there.
In fact, he put the nail
in our coffin of our theory
about zombie movement.
But I'll tell you
about that later.
So I think what happened
was because the early zombie
cultures didn't really
care about the mechanism,
there was lots of
different explanations.
From a biological
standpoint, it doesn't
seem like that
would be the case.
So I like the idea of the
infection theory of zombieism.
AUDIENCE: So like a latent--
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Yeah.
The real phenomenon that I think
fascinates me the most in this
is toxoplasmosis.
So toxoplasmosis is a
single cell organism.
It's what lives in cat poop.
And it's why pregnant women
shouldn't be around cat poop.
It's because it induces
flu-like symptoms
if you get the infection.
And it'd be dangerous to
fetuses and young children.
But normally, if you're
an adult and you get it,
you just get a flu.
It seems to go away.
But really what happens is
it's a single organism that
reproduces sexually in
the gut of a feline.
So that's where it gets
its most genetic diversity.
When it's outside the feline,
it can only reproduce asexually.
So it clones itself.
So what this organism does
is even after the infection,
it stays latent in your system.
And in the mammals
that it infects,
so the rodents,
humans, it actually
starts modifying the
neuropharmacology
of the individual's brain.
And what you see is you see
characteristic behavioral
differences in people who have
had toxoplasmosis assistant
and survived versus
those who don't.
And the most
classic case of this
was an experimental
study where they
took a rat-- and rats
normally hate cats.
They're instinctively
afraid of cats-- gave it
a toxoplasmosis intervention.
And across time, if
you had a glass wall
between the rat and the cat,
normally the rat's over here.
But as the infection
rate occurs,
the rat actually
starts to not only
not be afraid, but want
to be near the cat.
So there's increased
risk taking behavior
that happens as a
result of the infection.
And actually, that same kind
of behavior, not towards cats
obviously, but more
risk taking behavior
is seen in individual
human individuals
who've had the infection.
So somehow, the
single cell organism
is hijacking the
complex circuits that
induce our ability to be
afraid of certain things
and it increased risk taking.
So that coupled with the
popularization of the infection
theory of zombies is the
more interesting link there.
And if you're going to ask me
about biologically plausible,
with the caveat that it's
still way, way far away,
that is more the route that you
would see something like this.
AUDIENCE: OK.
This is more than the
rat simply becoming
acclimated to having a cat on
the other side of the wall.
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Yeah.
So you don't see
it all in rats that
have never exposed to the virus.
They stay far away.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The other question
I had, pretty quickly.
So you talked about the amygdala
and rage and anger aggression.
So I've heard of Kluver-Bucy
syndrome, which is basically
uncontrolled appetite.
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You didn't talk
much about why the appetite
side, rage can be all sorts
of aggressive behavior.
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Yeah.
So Kluver-Bucy syndrome is
a rare neurological disorder
that happens-- it
can only occur when
you get both amygdala damaged.
And they exhibit
hyperorality, hypersexuality.
And it's a very odd
characteristic feature.
So you caught a
hole in our theory.
Because according to our theory,
zombies should be hyperoral,
hypersexual.
They should also
be hyperfearful,
because the amygdala actually
controls fight and flight.
So what it's doing is
if you leave it intact,
zombies should be just as
easily spooked as pissed off.
So you did catch the
hole in the theory.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
different way.
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Right.
Right.
All right.
Any more questions?
OK.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So with this
CDC blog post a while
ago about what to do in the
event of a zombie outbreak,
do you have any
critiques of that?
Did they do a good job?
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: I loved that.
I thought they did a great job.
Because really,
what they were doing
is epidemic preparedness
and emergency preparedness,
but just couched in zombies.
It got people's attention.
It got people excited
about doing it.
Instead of just
doing, OK, we're going
to pretend that there's
a SARS virus out,
people habituate
to these things.
But if you do it tongue in
cheek, people got engaged.
I think it got a lot more
people interested in thinking
about preparedness for
epidemics and emergencies
than if they had just done
anything else, except for maybe
now, they could probably
do it with ebola.
But otherwise, yeah, I
thought it was a great idea.
And I like seeing agencies
do that tongue in cheekness
to engage in awareness
and attention.
Did you still have
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just real quick.
First of all, thank
you, super helpful.
I added more cardio into my life
after I watched "Zombieland."
So now, I feel more prepared.
The second was, do you and your
friends at the Zombie Research
Society plan on doing research
into other parts of the zombie
body, so beyond the brain?
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Yeah.
So we did a Reddit AMA.
And one of the questions
was about the gut system.
And the next avenue
of zombie science
is zombie internal medicine.
Because how do zombies
get their nutrients
when you've got your entrails
dragging on the ground?
I think that's a
fascinating question.
So I think that getting
people interested in talking
about digestive systems
and poop is normally not
that interesting.
But you couch it in zombies,
it can be interesting.
Same with cardiac
systems and blood systems
from a biological angle.
I think there's lots
on the biological side
that you could explore
on the zombie body,
because their physiology.
How do you explain how
you could have somebody
that's got thick,
goop, viscous blood
but somehow still
manages to be animated?
So yeah, that would be a fun
avenue on the biological side.
And of course, on
the social side,
you can use zombies
to explain anything,
different hierarchical
societies.
Zombie cognitive phenomenon
would be really interesting.
So I don't really
think there's anything
you can't do with zombies just
because they keep changing.
They're not like
vampires and werewolves,
which have a very
static structure.
Zombies keep changing with time.
So you can always
find an example
of a zombie doing something
that you want to study.
But yeah, I'm waiting for
the zombie internal medicine.
AUDIENCE: So one connection
that you didn't touch on
is between rabies and zombieism.
I've heard people
talk about that.
Any comments on whether rabies
would be or a form of rabies--
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: So a
longer version of the talk,
we actually go over this.
Because when we go over the
memory systems and the impulse
control systems, those
are all linked up
to a system known as
the Papez circuit.
That's a classic
neurological circuit
that was discovered
in the 1930s.
And it was discovered
using the rabies virus.
And so what this guy
James Papez would do
is he was trying to find
the link between emotion
and intention.
How is it that we can't remember
what we did at the store
yesterday, but
everybody remembers
where they were at 9/11?
How do we have these
emotional bonding of memories?
And so he mapped out
this theoretical circuit
and then would map it out in
cats by injecting the rabies
virus and watching the
virus propagate from one
area to the next, look
for the connections.
And he actually made cats
that were memory problems.
They were hyperaggressive.
So we do a tongue in
cheek thing saying
that James Papez made
the first zombie cats.
But the rabies virus is a very
specific type of infection.
And it's very general.
So what it does is it
attacks a particular cell,
jumps across what's known
as the synapse, which
is the gap between cells,
and keeps propagating down
to the next cell.
And it just wanders.
It just follows
from place to place.
So if you get an infection
in one part of the brain,
it's-- where it goes
is determined by who
it's connected with.
And it'll keep traveling
until it basically
kills the organism.
Now, normally you
get some symptoms
like the cognitive disorders.
You'll get delusions and
dementia with rabies infection.
You get hydrophobia.
So individuals infected
with the rabies virus
will be afraid of water.
They won't drink.
They'll become dehydrated.
And some of those are
explained by the virus
doesn't survive well when
there's lots of brain swelling.
So it automatically
dehydrates you
to keep that brain
swelling down.
Things like that
have been put forth
as explanations for
those kind of behaviors.
But a lot of them
just happen to be--
people show those when the
virus has spread so far
throughout the brain as
to basically wipe away
most of the neocortex.
And so it's nonspecific in the
sense of where it's attacking.
But we really start
to see the symptoms
once it's just so widespread
as to be catastrophic.
So yeah, the rabies
virus has been
linked to zombies more
times than anything else.
So the book "World War Z,"
the first name for the virus
was African rabies,
because they first
talked about in South Africa.
And there's been a lot of
movies that talk tongue
in cheek about a
rabies-like infection.
That's just because more of
the hyperaggressive, impulsive
responses.
But we don't really see
how that's occurring yet
until you get to this
catastrophic stage.
AUDIENCE: You also see that
with the association of bites.
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN:.
Yeah
AUDIENCE: Rabies
get's transmitted--
TIMOTHY VERSTYNEN: Right.
Oh that's true.
That's true.
Yeah, so it's a good
infectious disease that way,
to use as a metaphor.
Yeah.
All right.
Any other questions?
Thank you guys very much.
Thanks for inviting me out.
Happy Halloween.